joining us now with reaction Democratic
strategist Doug Shon Fox News
contributor Joe koncha and a senior
fellow at the Hoover institution Victor
Davis Hansen Doug I want to start with
you the president has been firm in
saying I'm running I'm running I'm
running and I have said I don't see a
Universe where President Biden doesn't
run but I did see those two pieces the
axios piece and then I see the political
one that it's an everpresent waight
Hunter legal troubl so do you think that
there's any chance he pulls back from
his
run you know Kaylee a month or two ago I
would have agreed with you and said no
chance he's not running and I think in
his mind today he is running but that
being said with poll numbers as bad as
his numbers with an approval at
33% and with the impeachment inquiry
having been opened and his obvious
cognitive challenges I think he'll have
a family meeting over the holidays and
whether he decides to run or not
ultimately I still think is an open
question so I think this is an evolving
story and let's stay tuned and wait till
January yeah very interesting Victor I
want to come to you because I want to
give a war word of warning to viewers
the polls haven't always been right
there was supposed to be a red wave
there was not when you look at Trump and
the voters he's bringing in he's
bringing in young voters he's bringing
in all kinds of new voters but non 2020
voters in the CNN poll he's winning by
26 in Georgia and 40 in Michigan but you
got to make a non- 2020 voter show up in
2024 you've got to get out the
vote yeah but I I think it's a little
different um Kaye I think he's in a doom
loop it's not just the polls none of his
agenda is polling anything he's done is
polling 50% he's got some really
problems with the Biden family
conglomerate that finally the the the
news of their skull duggery is it's
unass it's unassailable and then in
addition to
that uh he's got I I'll be frank he's
he's in severe cognitive decline and
when you add all of that up corruption
decline low poles and unpopular agenda
the result is we're in enoy there's
lethargy now we we've seated the Red Sea
over to the yemeni terrorists you can't
navigate it we have had 125 attacks on
our installations Iran and we're not
doing anything there's no border it's
not that it's poorest it doesn't exist
and then they're infighting to take up
that vacuum in the white house because
we hear that Kamala Harris thinks she
she we should be more sympathetic to
Hamas or that people are saying we've
got to Outlaw natural gas but on the
same time we've got to produce more gas
and oil we ever have so because of this
Decline and this vacuum people are
freelancing around him with different
agendas are not compatible and overseas
people see nothing getting done and
they're taking advant AG of that vacuum
and they're our
enemies that's right I mean that's a
good summary and Joe you know for Joe
Biden to win though he needs to make
Democrats come home when you look at his
approval rating which is almost in the
20s shocking to say he's lost 12 points
among Democrats do you think they come
home that's the thing he's losing among
black voters he's losing among female
voters independent voters young voters
all the people that helped him barely
win in 2020 they are leaving and
probably not coming back because the
thought process is ky will this
President get better with age will he be
like Bill Clinton The Comeback Kid well
no he's not whine he's not going to get
better with age and then when you think
about the version of Joe Biden as an 86
year old in the Oval Office if he won a
second term it's it's hard for any
Democrat really to imagine that and no
President Kelly has ever been reelected
with an approval rating below 40% and as
Doug pointed out we're now seeing
several polls putting him at 30 3% so
apparently political Rock Bottom has a
basement and by the way have you seen
the president's schedule today and I'm
not just cherry-picking because this is
a lot of days 10:00 a.m. he got the
daily intelligence brief because
terrorists apparently like to sleep in
on Fridays and then 12:30 he had lunch
with the vice president and that's it
that's when the weekend began despite
everything happening in the world people
see this they know it and you cannot
spin it to the media even they are
starting to reject this notion that Joe
Biden can serve another four years
kayy yeah Doug how do you reverse that
perception that's a very difficult thing
to do when the American public has their
mind made
up well I think Joe Biden gave us a hint
Kayley he said he wouldn't be running
but for Donald Trump running again I
think the Playbook is to run the same
campaign that was run in 2018 2020 and
2022 which is a negative full out
campaign against Donald Trump because
while I it pains me to say as a Democrat
I can't disagree with what Victor said
about how people feel about his
performance and how objectively his
performance should be judged the only
saving grace for Biden is in some of
those swing States he's within the
margin of error and Donald Trump's
numbers personally are almost as low in
some of those States as Joe Biden yes
he's trailing it may be a death Loop but
it can be a death Loop for both
candidates stes which is what I think
the Biden strategy would have to
be Victor I only have a moment here but
do you think Joe Biden's the nominee
come next
summer I I really don't Kay I don't know
how the mechanism will transpire but I
think people in the Democratic party
understand he he's not cognitive AEL and
the idea of CA Harris assuming the
presidency maybe before his term is over
and running is incumbent is one of their
worst nightmares so I'm I'm not even
sure she's going to fin he's going to
finish his
term yeah that that's a scary thought
Joe Kona Doug shown Victor Davis Hansen
thank you